siccome ragazzi mi avete chiesto un paio
di video fa come mai avevo fatto una
scena col cappello di lana che siamo in
estate si muore di caldo è deciso di
farci un intero video costa minchia di
cappello anche se sento l'inferno tra i
capelli non me ne frega una mazza da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
sugli assi muletto si è assunto fatto
stampa ma non sono riuscito a fare un
casino di casa e quindi voglio vedere se
riesco a farle adesso cosa cazzo fa quel
prezioso a pasto tizio che ha sta
ballando insieme a to valleys una diga
massei deficiente a william da pacas
perché io sono una capra che può fare
ste cose
braccata cazzo soli mo basta dica poi
trasversi è la madonna chiacchiaro ho
fatto un salto ragazzi ma che cazzo ci
ha stanica di strano che non capita ma
tu le tratti così le signore non sia
proprio un pezzo di merda fatto ti sta
bene stronzo perché l'amore alla fine
trionfa sempre ricordato ragazzi perché
c'è un cazzo di ufo schiantato la diga
non cos'è sto schifo si muove ragazzino
qualsiasi cosa sia sim si è mosso
possono e carlo posso regalare a è una
capra questo che no vabbè ma questa è
questa la cosa più bella che abbia mai
visto madonna è certo di creare questa
dove lo metti audio no no no questo no
pacchia [ __ ] dove so chi opera di
montagna sale le montagne col suo skate
senza che nessuno si accorga di lei
della sua bellissima chioma vai vai vai
chiamate filed under e dri ok che si
fotta lo skate rega che si fotta quella
merda di schema pochi e cado
no no no su torni su ma li mortacci tua
di tua sorella ma [ __ ] sesta
torcia una torcia dal mattino
salve ragazzi c'è una notizia capra
bellissima salve è svenuta perfetto
questo l'effetto che faccio io le donne
che bella gnocca
puoi vedere come si fa skate da dove vai
vieni qua no no no no no no no no non è
la pista da dall'altra parte è bello c'è
un concetto di skate tutto mio regalo
prega ama vola sto skate
[Musica]
ho trovato una cosa fottutamente epica
guardate che roba chiama anche in
assassin's creed se cose fatemi capire
come una capra partorì non l'ho mai
vista ve lo dico già ole ole ole dio mio
santo questo fa fare sto pezzo
sì sì l'ho fatta faccio fare tutto si va
beh ma che sono le ninja no sì sì invece
sono ninja messo mezz'ora per tornare
qua sopra quindi o ci riesce o ci riesci
a madonna ragazzi cè un tubo non so che
cosa ci sta a fare un tubo ma io ci
entrò len trophy repulsivi powered games
è una cosa cosa cazzo ci fanno le
tartarughe ninja qua dentro io sono più
forte le tartarughe ninja togliti dai
[ __ ] ragazza ok va a fan capra
contro tartarughe la cosa più giusta
assieme a tante rogani jersey shore rega
non ho ben capito che cosa ci sta a fare
stessa roba sono macchie quelli che si
ed è anche io non scherzo salve sentite
c'è mica una fila da rispettare chi no
perché sono fa vj io sono fa grazie
mille mediche tutti mi conoscono ragazzi
cosa cazzo sto facendo qui dietro stili
forse perché mi prendono a calci
pezzenti ecco so che lega la gente
prende anche io sto prendendo comunque
se io riuscissi ad andare magari via da
te ma perché l'immondizia e mia nemica
puoi schiantarti dove cazzo vuoi
hannibal sentiva affanculo questo si
schianta sulla prima cosa che bene ma lo
fa apposta perché gli piace masochista
io prendo una bici grazie e grazie mille
molto gentili mi si è incaricata
perfetto nel muro di semplice mi si è
bloccata la vicina il muro mi piace
andare in bici ma che cazzo
l'ottica di lega sono io io vado in bici
così è normalissimo ok perfetto salve a
buongiorno lei che sta aspettando
l'autobus come sta
ragazzi aiuto aiutano
ma tranquilli tranquilli avviato una
buona giornata a tutti quanti suo
salotto non solo un attimino indemoniato
tutto normale
vabbè fuori il controllo della nutella
se è possibile non va beh non fa niente
grazie mille ragazzi stiamo andando
non so dove voglio fare troppo una cosa
fermi un attimo come t
no no
noli sdraio non volevo uccidere ecco
perfetto come non detto ragazzi siamo di
nuovo esorcizzati ama perfetto ma posso
spegnerlo alle pre le pale eoliche non
ancora viste se sto tizio la smettessero
calcio un tizio non aspettate che l'ho
visto vieni qui è perché c'è un tizio
[ __ ] di sel c'è una un albero ma
cosa cazzo sarebbe quello che lo vedete
anche voi è una cosa o dio
sì perché un cazzo di aiuto via via via
via via più che perfetto visto ho visto
un tizio brutto
l'ho visto un tizio molto brutto cano
piano piano sulle varie io vorrei capire
che questa questa bellezza non ragazzi
chicchi cos'è sta roba il demone delle
capre ma [ __ ]
ho vinto io so che se senti mister collo
lungo ascolta un attimo che vorrei
capire cosa non fatto incassare la capra
dal coro lunga amico vero aiuto vieni
con me vieni come bastardo che ti
insegno io le buone maniere è in testa
bellissima fatelo dire quanti letti
lecco proprio ma [ __ ] sentite
fatemi salire con sopra che è meglio
dove stiamo andando
c'è una c'è una pala eolica e allora se
la lecco faccio lo sapevo ed è così
ragazzi che si fa il patè di capra credo
mentale buon uomo che stai si sta
stendendo su questo bidone senta lei
buonomo che cade a ce la fate a stare in
piedi più di due secondi ragazzi può
salire sulle montagne russe così credo
la si vede che passa è che testata
ragazzi e michael jackson
la sfida impossibile
sì sì l'ho preso ed è così che io prendo
le montagne russe normalmente così così
è meglio termiche e fantastico grande
per fermi ha scaraventato in acqua
meraviglioso possono anche o no no non
mi non mi sto inglobando tua moglie lei
che sta tentando di perfetto è andata
piange no scherzo amico mio non piangere
sto scherzando vieni che in gruppo anche
tenere eccolo lì perfetto ruoli in
gruppi tutti o non i gruppi nessuno
perché non è che puoi fare 161 una quasi
offendono ragazzi e lei la casa è che la
gente continua a svenire a caso albe
bella gnocca
ci rivediamo dopo un po di tempo si
scusi per la panchina in faccia non
volevo farti seppi nonostante passi il
tempo è sempre pignocca e io lo sono
ancora di più
salutate il nuovo re capra perché
stavolta se lo merita e tu che cosa c'è
da mandare donna mostra le tette subito
a ragazzi per concludere miike cosa sta
roba
do not leak non le care perfetto la
prima cosa che ho fatto e le carlo
perché mi sembrava giusto cosa cazzo
sono diventato ragazzino diventato una
capra fosforescente ragazzi non ho ben
capito che serve sta cosa ma lo scoprirò
nel prossimo episodio perché per ora
linee di concludere qui perché ho visto
abbastanza per oggi i ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto lasciato il momento mi
piace anche a voce cosa cazzo è successo
sono stato sfar sfrecciato da qualche
parte nell'universo parallelo va va bene
ragazzi sia il video è piaciuto e come
ho fatto a tornare qui non mi faccio
domande se se vi do è piaciuto questo
momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video tratte nella
descrizione allestite per i siti
scriveteli ci vediamo al prossimo
vitobello ragazzi